l'alerte anti-aérienne a maintenant été
levée à Kiev après plus de 4 heures
passées dont les abris les habitants de
la capitale ukrainienne sont de nouveau
autorisés à sortir voyez un peu ces
images du métro
ukrainien ou la population a désormais
pris l'habitude de ce réfugier ce sont
des dizaines de drones Iraniens qui ont
été tirés ce matin sur la ville des
missiles de croisière également ont été
tirés par la Russie qui ne relâche pas
on le voit bien la pression Emmanuel
chasse bonjour vous êtes notre envoyé
spécial à Kiev vous venez tout juste de
sortir de votre abri l'alerte a donc été
levée
oui tout à fait Elisabeth l'alerte de ce
matin elle a duré plus de 4 heures et
elle a fait suite à une alerte pendant
la nuit qui elle a une attaque russe de
drone kamikaze qui elle a duré plus près
de 4 heures également au milieu de la
nuit donc vous imaginez le calvaire
enduré par des millions de personnes ils
non seulement ici dans la capitale mais
aussi à travers tout le pays lorsqu'il y
a de telles alertes alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a des personnes qui ignorent les
avertissements mais la plupart des gens
quand même vont se mettre à l'abri on a
tous en tête les les frappes sur les
infrastructures
civiles comme il y a quelques jours
seulement à ni pro dans la ville de ni
pro et ce matin de nouvelles
infrastructures et de nouvelles de
nouvelles zones résidentielles ont été
touchées ici à Kiev il y a eu au moins
deux explosions pour l'instant on n'a
pas accès aussi c'est le gouvernement
demande aussi de ne pas diffuser d'image
afin de ne pas aider la graisse russe à
identifier ces cibles donc
sais pas ce qu'on sait ce matin le maire
de Kiev Vitali Klitschko a annoncé qu'il
y avait sur l'un des sites des
explosions déjà un mort et deux blessés
à déplorer on a appris pendant cette
dernière attaque aérienne que
l'Allemagne allait bientôt livrer c'est
léopard II à Kiev c'est charlour
arriveront fin mars début avril des
renforts et un calendrier c'est ce que
réclamé depuis des mois voleody
mirzelinski
tout à fait ça fait près d'un an ça fait
pratiquement depuis le début de cette
guerre que Vladimir Zelinski réclamait
aux alliés occidentaux de l'armement
lourd des chars et pour vous donner une
idée hier il a évidemment exprimé sa
gratitude auprès du chancelier allemand
et aussi du président américain pour les
promesses faites et les a salués comment
premier pas ça sous-entend qu'il en
attend d'autres il attend également des
avions de combat et plus d'armements
lourds la ligne la ligne de front à
l'est elle fait plus de 1000 km c'est
donc autant de terrain à défendre ou à
libérer de l'agresseur russe et c'est
pour ça que même si ces annonces de
livraison de chars elles sont très très
bien vu ici qui est fait elles arrivent
elles soulage en fait à la fois le
gouvernement et la population qui place
beaucoup d'espoir dans ce matériel mais
ici on veut surtout les voir c'est pas
seulement les promesses qui comptent
c'est de pouvoir voir ce matériel arrivé
en Ukraine de pouvoir savoir que que les
ukrainien seront entraînés au manoeuvre
et que enfin ces armes lourdes seront
visibles à l'est du pays notamment dans
la région du Dombas merci beaucoup
Emmanuel Chaze en direct donc de Kiev
pour